if you know armageddon comes and you
know we it's either
each other so i'm eat theo's ass first
or i'm eating nick's pooch i'm probably
going pooch then your ass are you really
yeah i mean you asked first daddy oh
like a chocolate rabbit on easter
chant what do you what will you have
chin
a mark looks pretty tasty right now i
don't know i'd go with something small
dawg one of y'all's dicks
[Laughter]
you ever met this guy oh i'm the dumb
one you can't argue there's something
about me you have no idea what you're
saying gang gang buzz bug
what kind of day is it uh it's a day to
celebrate because we're finally together
dude
been a long run i miss you brother
good to see you today man how you doing
man doing good dude i um you look tanner
huh oh thanks man i feel good i was just
been out in the sun i saw a guy on the
road
when i was driving who was um
uh getting flowers off the interstate
i did that
you did really yep and i didn't have he
didn't have change i just gave him a
hundred buckaroos i said how much does
this get me gave me like six dozen
flowers like what do you mean for
mother's day
brought it home to my my mother-in-law
my girl oh six dozen flowers he ran in
traffic man he earned it earned it no i
saw a guy on the who had pulled over on
the side of the road he was uh getting
flowers off the side of the interstate
he was getting um
like he saw him digging up plants and
stuff or getting plants you know well
are those free plants
i think so no
right i don't look like on a government
establishment you probably can't have
those also ditch onions
yeah i guess i don't know what the rule
what the
interstate plants hey if chin's acting
all different today it's only a matter
of time for chin leaves us chin has a
live concert tonight and he's all
nervous about it well chin always looks
like he's about to perform on a cruise
ship yeah it's not unusual to be loved
by anyone what do we got here
can you
take
can you take plants oh i put plans
you put plant let me see can you take
plants from
public park
plants don't put no why corporate plants
well no you can grab carrots and [ __ ]
unless on somebody's actual property it
is illegal to collect wild plants
national parks national monuments
national forests state parks most local
parks along highway rights of the way
without a permit so the highway oh
brendan
you're just saying a bunch of sounds
dude
it's illegal to collect english language
in national parks that's chauvinism
national monuments national forest state
parks and most local parks along
highways
right away without a permit
usually usually against the law
what does it say usually
oh it does it's usually there's a lot of
wiggle room there yeah is it just go to
the flower shop though you know
how long do i pretend that you're dead
broke
i didn't do it i saw a guy i was driving
there's a guy one of your neighbors out
here who is
borrowing interstate
plants foliage i mean it's the thought
that counts if there were they nice
flowers or it was like [ __ ] i
couldn't know i was doing probably 68
man and one of my tires is low so it's
uh the visual i was getting was uh
it was definitely had a filter on yeah
you know welcome to my life
it's called ct bubba what yeah what
could my life is it yeah the lenses are
a little blurred for me oh we know yeah
we know that baby
um
[Music]
you look tan dude thanks man i feel good
i was just working out outdoors
yesterday here's a call we got a call
right here from a guy do you feel weird
that it's just you and me right now
i don't think so no me neither it feels
nostalgic feels right feels right it
feels good the boys are back in town it
definitely feels easier i feel like i
feel more relaxing
um this is where there's less people
yeah there's less yeah there's less
personalities that navigate you know
eric singing chris is [ __ ] i would
say at moments i was noticing some
frustration of theo about to begin a
story and repeatedly getting cut off if
i just had to
but you have to look at your facial
expressions sometimes i'd say probably
sometimes it feels sometimes like
there's not a lot of room um
but you got two big personalities that's
used to you know it's like we were just
it was it was two brothers and they
bring home you know two more [ __ ]
kids you know you and we're not getting
the same attention yeah feral orphans
yeah yeah
yeah they brought home a big tall bird
and a half black guy
you know we're like okay guess what and
very light on the half black let's don't
give eric much black i mean i respect
that he's genetically his you know
you know is claiming black no there's
more cream than black coffee in his it's
more like half white half i feel like
senior citizen that's fair you know but
detroit senior citizen
you know what i'm saying like a little
bit of uh
um
he reminds me who does eric remind me of
sometimes
he reminds me of a professor i think
that's easy especially because of the
glasses but yeah the teacher he's always
trying to educate us but in driver's ed
and strong as well that's true because
he's always trying to educate yes always
try to give us a different perspective
yeah do you have snacks in that jacket
it looks like you you're carrying some
stuff yeah
just so you look like you sell the worst
kratom on venice beach
hey
you're trying to crowd him yeah he wants
a bag of that crowd
all right what's this dude want nick
this guy obviously is doing pretty well
for himself is this uh for halloween or
this guy's always real postal huh
what up king
dean i got you a trailer park hack
so as a mailman we got rubber bands gang
baby rubber bands hell yeah rubber bands
rubber band man
so
we don't got the money bands mm-hmm so
we can't afford belts so
yeah um
work [ __ ] great
theo i got you one right here oh yeah
it's a nice video
how about you boy
can't be worse than that's in the lower
zoo you tried well it's an idea that's a
touchy subject all right you're welcome
okay gang baby yeah well i think
especially if you have a if you're
trying to get i respect this guy dude
first of all working for the postal
system still you know because remember
postal became a term it used to be a job
and then it became going post
something yeah you know and it was like
at that time to still be to still be
like you know what i'ma ride this out
i think that's uh that's valiant man
this dude is a real you know a real king
arthur right here and he's going door to
door dropping off your mail dealing with
dogs that's their number one enemy is
dog is it still yeah man rottweilers
little chihuahuas look that up tim
what's the most danger for postal
workers yeah well uh type in how many uh
postal workers attacked by dogs every
year it's
surprising that i feel like that's not
what we're looking for i feel like what
we're looking for is what is the most
danger for him because you're saying his
dogs i don't know if his dogs i feel
like what else would it be inclement
weather
um
other animals raccoons first of all are
way more prevalent than dogs are
there's way more raccoon dogs no sir
that's not no okay
they mentioned dogs here
what fear of dogs
ten percent of postal employees listed
as the thing that fair most on the job
is dogs ten percent
that's not that much hey
hey go down go down
many postal workers get bit by dogs
click on that chin says people also ask
click on that
one percent that's stupid oh that's a
light bro how much issue is that i
thought it was a real problem how much
issue is raccoons with postal workers
there we go there's raccoons all over
the world hell yeah bro
raccoon is native to north america and
can be found throughout the u.s i was
trying to find out if there are more
dogs or raccoons still working on it
there's dogs
brendan you don't know that man yeah i
do dude trash pandas how many how many
dogs you see today
what is today
tuesday
i haven't seen any oh wait actually
that's not true
i saw three dogs this morning this lady
this old lady was walking these dogs and
dude these dogs looked so
i don't think this lady could see
because these dogs look bad bro being
like malnourished one of them looked
like he didn't know how to eat anymore
bruh and she was still taking him out
there walking him and she was just kind
of it was like two of them kind of dang
like just like nudging the other one
like the last one trying to help him out
yeah just on its last limb bro there
there's an um what is that that's a
pygmy raccoon oh definitely there's less
than a thousand of those
but he's like the small one
yeah and can they cut their nails so
they don't mess up the furniture look at
there's one in the city right there wow
raccoon in the city how much raccoons
are you guys can't get this into
astonishing surge over the last 80 years
uh dogs are 900 million
that's simon close fellas come on
how many people have pet [ __ ] trash
pandas think about it but bro think
about mother nature she's the ultimate
pet owner and she has as many as she
wants dog and they know how to hide
they're in the whitney they're basically
mother nature's witness protection
20 million nick what is it nick took it
down it said 20 million you did yes
20 million how many what are you doing
what animal is it trash pandas oh yeah i
did say 20 million in the world global
population might be 20 million in north
america there's 900 million dogs who's
david though why does he know he's a
professor yeah politics
no it says trash panda expert cool he's
not a professor he just he uh he
registered as a he has a um political
science racoons are political so north
dakota political science though dude
says the population might push to 50
million at some point
it's not even close let's say he's off
by a hundred let's say he's off by 500
million it's not even close
i don't believe there's 900 million dogs
in the world that sounds
is say bro what it would be
an epidemic dog
that's a no for me dawg that's a note
for me to hug what up king stinging the
wing fans let's take a moment to talk
about draftkings the nba playoff action
is nonstop and draftking sportsbook an
official sports betting partner of the
nba this week new customers can bet just
five dollars y'all you hear what i said
you bet just five dollars on any team to
win and get
150 dollars in free bets what
150 dollars in free bets with five
dollars you can't turn that down you're
looking to turn the small bet into a big
payday during the nba playoffs with
draftkings same game parlays you can do
just that
create your own parlay by combining
multiple bets like which team will win
total three-pointers made total rebounds
assists all those great nba stats to be
looking at while we're watching the game
boom and have a shot at even bigger
payout right now all customers can place
the same game parlay with three or more
legs and get a free bet back up to 25
if one leg doesn't hit you get that free
bet back up to 25 if one leg doesn't hit
download the draftkings sports app now
use promo code cats that's k-a-t-s
bet five dollars on any nba team to win
their game and get 150 dollars in free
bets if they do that's promo code cats
only at draftkings sportsbook minimum
age and eligibility eligibility
restrictions apply see show notes for
details
king sting wing sing fans if you like me
let's talk about liquid
ivy
i use liquid iv i work out on my rowing
machine and then i throw some liquid iv
one of my favorite flavors watermelon
into 16 ounces of water and i stay
hydrated liquid iv keeps you wet
when you push your body too hard and you
just feel run down it's extremely
important to stay hydrated making
hydration at priority helps you better
on a day-to-day basis liquid iv
hydration comes in refreshing flavors
like i said my favorite watermelon lemon
lime strawberry oh i love the pina
colada too that's another one of my
favorites liquid iv
i told you guys i use it i love it you
should use it too one stick of liquid iv
and 16 ounces of water hydrates faster
than and more efficiently than water
alone contains five essential vitamins
b3 b5 b6 b12 and vitamin c with three
times the electrolytes of the
traditional sports drinks made with
premium ingredients designed to enhance
rapid absorption of water other key
ingredients into the bloodstream liquid
rv has donated over 20 million servings
globally grab liquid iv in bulk
nationwide at costco or you can get 25
off when you go to liquid iv.com and use
code cats k-a-t-s at checkout that's 25
off anything you order when you use
promo code cats at liquidity.com
experience better hydration today at
liquid iv.com promo code cats stay
hydrated
chin yeah come on what come on
you know what i'm talking it is true
though they do eat dogs in korea which
sucks
not a lot but it doesn't suck if you
have if you have nothing to eat yeah
that's your thing i mean if you're poor
and no but still you shouldn't kill dogs
for me dude when i grew up people was
eating all kind of stuff bro like what
uh people would eat rabbit people would
eat armadillo meat oh a little armadillo
jerky yeah what else did that mean
something was really unique that they
had i saw recently somebody eat little
armadillo on the grill looks like a
little artichoke
i'd see a couple brothers grilling up a
dove all the time bob brass of the sky
are they doves that's what i call them
they're peace birds aren't they pigeons
pigeons are rats of the sky
these are beautiful huh yeah they pull
up a dove
they're just you know what they call
them beautiful because they're white
well i'm sick of people beating down on
asian people for eating dogs like if you
live in a country where dogs don't you
know here dogs have a lot of rights they
have opportunities they have television
shows you know you give them land they
got movies running networks in other
countries dogs is just bro you know what
i'm saying that's just a little dinner
you know
this is a dinner with a little neck
brace on a little wall what's it called
choker yeah a little choker electric
chocolate here we put like different
things like um we dress them up we put
the address on at its name it's like
fluffy 212 like brooks avenue we put
chair they put on add cumin on the
freaking deck
like damn okay
and this one's sauteed that's survival
we you know it's dude i'm not hating on
him man you gotta do what you gotta do
the second the electricity goes out dude
every one marauder in this [ __ ]
country is gonna be on the grill oh i'll
barbecue up nick's little [ __ ] pooch
right now people wanna act like oh i
would just stay here forever with my dog
there's a guy whose wife left him and he
was making love to a dog on youtube she
left it up for two years yeah sure and
that's in a park that's in a city park
and here's the thing if you know
armageddon comes and you know we it's
either eat
each other so i'mma eat theo's ass first
or i'm eating nick's pooch i'm probably
going pooch then your ass are you really
yeah i mean you asked first daddy oh
like a chocolate rabbit on easter
you ain't getting none of this bro i'll
take i'll eat my own ass before i die
then
you ain't getting none of this you
pervert [ __ ] i'ma hold you down dog
champ what do you what will you have ken
my mark looks pretty tasty right now
okay that looks like tough meat
does it yeah i like lean meats though
gmo and [ __ ] i don't know i'd go with
something small dawg one of y'all's
dicks
[Laughter]
when did they get rid of the four inch
round that's when life changed bro
because then you couldn't go in the
subway and just get that little daddy
you're talking about a little saucer
sandwich yeah yeah that [ __ ] god damn
son
is subway still popping though i think
jared with all his [ __ ] and then you
dated his sister i think that date is
sick it was like two i met his sister
once at night
[Laughter]
okay you met her at a dinner and talked
to her for quite some time well
call it what you will brother the guy
alleged did he do that jared did they
bust he's in prison my man yeah yeah
do you think what percentage of fake
pedophiles are in prison do you think
honestly
uh negative
50
i think they're all you know it's kind
of
if you molested your own kids you think
you would call the cops on yourself or
not we got another trailer park hack
right here
this guy's got one all right thank you
this is travis from ohio and i heard
jonathan looking for some
so you might not have running water some
of us broke people don't i finally do
now i got well water so you can't go
baby
so you hook a hose up to
your spigot nothing not [ __ ] it you d
gin you get an adapter so you can hook a
second hose up okay you hook that to
your neighbor's house you turn their
water on too much work you open yours
and guess what pushes water right
through your house like you got running
water yeah reduce pressure but at 2 2am
nobody's gonna know you're out there
doing dishes filling buckets to flush
the toilet flush the toilet and doing
laundry so you're welcome gang gang buzz
buzz sore
wow does that not look like the starting
tight end for the niners who is that
jorge kittle and is he special or not
not boy white his name's george kettle
right yeah
they look similar nick give it up
thank you sir um
he also looks like a character from the
bible right there does he does not like
as if like you know jesus came back and
he's looking up in that image yeah like
easter sunday um i'll say this i think
getting free water from your neighbors
bro that's as old as time this is like
that's a lot of how you know people i
think a lot of uh
different tribes and stuff used to do it
if somebody had water you had to go get
the water
yeah it's the ultimate hustle really
water was the only thing that they had
back in the day that was like the main
currency wasn't it i think so in sugar
sugar
diamonds back in the day look at water
just to google water
you know what i'm saying look up water
but there's discrepancies
there's nothing better than that fresh
water from that hose
there's nothing like it there oh son
beretta can't [ __ ] with it and on a
summer day i just deep throat that hose
as a young kid
but why do you have to do that why can't
you just sip out of it because i can't
get enough
hmm
oh i don't think there's anything other
maybe that hot hoes hit baby the first
the first flush that would come out with
a lot of rust a lot of spiders a lot of
just the win whatever was from the
winter yeah and it's warm
yeah you see
your bone thugs and harmony playing out
of it like that first float bone bone
yeah tell me what you're gonna do that
first flush was thick maybe coming out
of that gun i enjoyed it man that's
god's gun baby dude so this guy just
posted bail from [ __ ] raiding the
capital that's cool
um this is bain sun isn't it little bane
professor x yeah but send in more
trailer park hacks as well yeah and look
i think that's one if you go there you
get your neighbor's hose you do that
defractor or whatever send the water
open up your ho open up your
uh
spigot and send the water right into
your own house dude load your house up
with water that's gangster but the
biggest gangster move is stealing
netflix and wi-fi that's the other
hustle from those trailer parks you
think yeah we're not paying for directv
and comcast and wi-fi you're stealing
from the neighbor but how do you get
netflix from them
you steal the code dog oh you put some
chops you put some charm you put some
charm on that big ass [ __ ] next door
yeah man i'm trying to see the squid
game girl yeah i'd love to see it
you download it you gotta get a [ __ ]
fresh water girl
you're gonna get straight murdered dawg
i didn't know where he was going but
that's a good plan that's a good plan
it's a horrible plan
you're out there at a barbecue sucking
on a mountain dew trying to get
somebody's netflix
like a couple damn meat queers bro y'all
need to chill out brothers let people
barbecue whatever it takes to get that
netflix password you feel me no no
whatever it takes what do you mean yeah
there's some fire content on there you
watch your special you but you can get
all kind of you can just go to um
there's also those free sites or
whatever you can get stuff on there like
tubi uh i don't know what it is
do you think anybody in trailer park
seven two three three
two is a porno site man 2v basically it
has i logged on the day it had videos
just from my phone that were just saved
to my phone
i'm like this is their content yeah
you're not going to go through this
hustle for 2b bro we want that high
quality hd yeah there's like an art
class like how to draw george washington
as one of the videos
like my grandma just figured out her
smart tv and she tells me she's been
watching stuff on tubey and rocco she
calls it
it's like oh i found something on rocco
i will say this man television some of
it's gotten so bad what's on there i
ended up watching the golden girls the
other night that's where yeah mike is
good yeah it's a good show my son you
know he doesn't have uh cable anything
in his room but he has a tv so it gives
free channels on there
it it you can only pick two two shows to
watch and
every episode of all time is fair factor
rogan on fairfax really and you watch it
he loves it you watch it how that you
could not make that show today man
why what happened with it they're ju
there's bullet they're covering blood
they're killing animals left and right
they're doing all sorts of dangerous
[ __ ] that show was lit dude well i think
that when you come when you're dealing
with killing animals bro you got it
sometimes a lot because how long do
animals even live
depends on the animal bro
well i don't know it's fun
but i'm saying how long does how long
can most animals live chin okay
well tortoise goddamn 100 years
ballpark i think most are 20 years right
that's probably the average animal life
crocodile 45 deer 35 dog 22. i feel like
that's 22. very aggressive deer and
shout out arby's who tried remember when
they tried having deer meat in there no
really pull that [ __ ] off
get the [ __ ] out y'all soft son
both of y'all [ __ ] is soft and there's
three of y'all see i'm gonna figure out
who i'm talking about
y'all [ __ ] soft son no way
arby's came with the [ __ ] deer baby
baby seven bucks thick cut venison and
crispy onions
that [ __ ] looks lit is that a
fillet why would they get rid of that
pull that [ __ ] up get that image on
there dog y'all scare y'all skeet y'all
skirting on the image for me bro they
ain't lying we got them
god that looks fantastic this thing got
some hoof in it look at that that big
mix dude biting into it this guy's great
dennison sandwiches at arby's
hell yeah
let's go baby i'm holding everyone today
i'm at arby's for one day only a limited
time zombie real quick this guy's me in
three years
this guy's been three years if things go
south
dude this dude is he likes to meet in
300 bro i'll tell you this bro
i love how these people act like it's
like today i'm i find myself that or
like it's
like it's harvey's fault that they're
there or like it's like oh i just got
anywhere ran into an army
well no bro you've been playing this all
[ __ ] night you've been there every
[ __ ]
day
dude and i hit mcdaniels last night bro
i roll up there okay it's late at night
this is what they had to sign because
they're making it hard to eat these days
bro
i roll up it says
only accepting uh bills less than 20
dollars right that's what it said no
credit cards only bills less than 20
dollars
so i
[ __ ] off
so i had to roll a couple blocks find a
dude an
outdoor guy or whatever vagrant
i break a 20 with him dude right i get
six dollars out of the deal okay
hell of a deal so i'm down 14
man and i went back and got a um
they do have a chicken sandwich it's a
little dry
and it doesn't compare much to
chick-fil-a and they're small right was
it small i didn't feel like it was small
but i felt like it was uh a little drier
but i did feel like the chicken was a
little thicker though here's the thing
six dollars at mcdaniels as you call it
for six dollars you feed a family of
four dogs no you're not yeah not these
days you're not not with these infants
they've got a dollar menu son huh they
got the dollar menu six sandwiches do
one of the one of the things on the
dollar menu is just somebody yelling the
n word that gets you through the speaker
so that's [ __ ] that ain't gonna feed
your daughter that's a dollar night yeah
yeah so so theo spent four of his
dollars on that
again
do it again one more time
all right i take two chicken sandwiches
man that's my
awesome
time
yeah i'm full
i feel good now man
i'll just take one chicken mcnugget if
you don't mind but what else that
venison go go back to you boy
i finally
started back over
dude yeah bro i i take this in
sandwiches at arby's bro bro a few more
hard breaks that's gonna be me in three
years and i'll be hitting up theo to
post it for me
i'm at arby's that's true one day only a
limited time to have their new venice
and sandwiches one thing better known as
bambi
sandwich features
okay a thick cut venison steak marinated
in garlic salt his mouth is cooked for
three hours to juicy perfection
and it's topped with crispy onions and a
cabernet steak sauce and food
carrying a bear baby on his side there
like toasted star top bun everyone i'm a
rhymer i'm slim shady anyway so that's
the
venison sandwich we need to let's zoom
this guy in next episode yeah this dude
yeah that's joey right there and i got
to say this man he gets out there and
he's 190 calories does he or does he
just stay in like a mile radius let's
see him fast food wait i'm sorry what
did you say i'm saying does he get out
there you just go to all the fast foods
in a mile radius that's a good call but
dude they hit that venison out the gate
let's see that first bite on joey that
sandwich looks fantastic
hmm big bite the big dog
brandon don't look how big his bite is
don't look at somebody's bite
dog look at that
that thing got some labby on it huh that
thing damn i think you got them freckles
that thing thick baby damn
they must have shot that [ __ ] in that
in that land over and buckingham
normal you would find at arby's
okay so
now i got the whole flavor of the
venison
and everyone's asking i know is he gamey
yeah i was gonna ask that
is it gamey
what do i think
i don't think so i think it's fine
well here's here my question is here's
my question if it ain't gamey then what
in the [ __ ] is it
it's just your normal army santa
you got hood wink baby with some antlers
though because i need a little gamey if
it's venison dog that's why i'm getting
it i want that [ __ ] to taste like dude
like a couple of angry white guys have
been chasing it yeah in a [ __ ] in a
uh
in a field man you got that i don't uh
game you know what that [ __ ] tastes
like a [ __ ]
i don't know whatever it tastes like
birthday cake yeah i want to give me as
[ __ ] i think it tastes like a [ __ ]
nintendo that's how gaming i want that
[ __ ]
i want that thing to taste like milton
bradley raised it though [ __ ] better
taste like a sega genesis being gaby
duck
god that guy's fantastic
hey king sting wing and the sing fans
this is your boy singh eric griffin
and i want to talk to you about skin
care from our sponsor looming skin if
your skin care routine is basically you
washing your face in the shower with
that one shower gel that you've been
using since high school then it's time
to level up that skin care game because
it turns out that regular body wash you
have been using that you thought was
good enough is probably damaging your
skin but thanks to lumen you can drop
that bottle of three in one and start
using products that actually take care
of your skin with lumen i get the
highest quality products all the
products aim to help with those stubborn
acne scars under eye dark circles
um
wrinkles sun damage dry skin oily skin
and more
starting with lumen is easy y'all all
you have to do is take the two minute
quiz on their website and they'll tell
you exactly which routine is best for
you based off your skin care needs all
the lumens crop products all of them
come with instructions so it's extremely
easy and will help protect your skin
from potential damage or future acne
plus all the products are made using
only natural ingredients that actually
work stuff like rose flower oil charcoal
powder ginger green tea and more guys i
swear skin care shouldn't be that
complicated thing we dread doing and
thanks to lumen it's simple
takes me less than 90 seconds out of my
day
lumen's great you got to use it level up
your skincare game with lumen skin today
go to lumenskin.com
cats to get your free trial of lumen
products that's l-u-m-i-n-skin
dot-com slash cats k-a-t-s to get your
free trial of lumen products
slash
lumenskin.com
so would y'all do it would y'all go
venison chin you guys i love venison
there you go it's one of my favorite
meats for sure for sure it's a little
gamey for me is it is it yeah i think
maybe the one
[ __ ] maybe the cut you got or something
but my i love it the cup what part do
y'all cut out what do y'all eat the
sirloin i think it is back straps
jenny's that hard yeah my friend goes
hunting so he gives me
some deer meat sometimes oh wow yeah
archery that sounds very much like a
brokeback mountain reference huh rogan
gave me some
sausage from [ __ ] deer meat or
something like that and it was too gamey
for me about to pretend it was the best
thing i've ever had yeah because how is
it dude unreal was it like blood sausage
or something that was regular sausage
but it's so gamey man with the eggs like
have regular standard street eggs mixed
with that gamey-ass you know venison
where the [ __ ] it was yeah there's a
real mix-up you got to get real eggs
that's the thing i think if you if you
go game you got to go full gamey you
know you need to get that full gameboy
yeah you need ditch onions you need uh
deer you need uh blueberries raspberries
what kind of other berries do they have
blackberries blackberries dude
boysenberries uh i don't know where boys
can you pull berries um
yeah that's what i want i want the
[ __ ] i want the bones
i want the cossacks hanging off i want
that little wet ass black nose hanging
on the side
pervert not all games racist bro that's
a boysenberry right there man oh that
[ __ ] dude literally those until
somebody always gets poisoned though
somebody always eats like the one that's
the wrong one by the one with the spikes
on it we go to beaver creek state park
in caledonia minnesota and fill them up
with a milk and a milk jug and then put
sugar on them
slight flex from nick
my grandmother used to put the yeah
freeze and put the sugar on them and
freeze them man god
the midwest they know how to do berries
man it's midwest acai yeah really i
didn't think about that it really really
is now chin you're trapped on a desert
island bro yeah right or a desert pet
shop
what do you have what do you think you
eat you're locked in a pet city at
aurora it has to be pets or just
anything look dude
man but let's say you know what i'm
saying let's say you definitely
you know it's like the kids section of
madagascar you know what i'm saying like
let's don't say you eating that lemur or
whatever yeah what you having on you
stuck in a uh
what's a popular pet store that's it
that's petsmart petsmart
so
educated pets
you over at petsmart now pets petsmart
got rid of puppies they got rid of birds
they have small gerbils and a lot of
fish and snakes right don't they have
snakes or no snakes lizards i would eat
snakes for sure wow yeah that would not
be my first guest oh yeah god i heard
rattlesnakes
how would you have it
well you kill them first and you skin
them you got it i've seen they get
afraid and i'll probably just deep fry
it with some batter oh you got a deep
frying pet smart now yeah you could make
a deep fryer in there
you could definitely commandeer a deep
fryer i think they're out of the uh oh
there's that washing area section where
they wash and they shave the pets
you're not hey bro you're a fisher by
trait you're not gonna eat the fish i
mean fish all over the place but what if
a texan gets trapped in there with you
got a little date night in there you
stuck at the pets trying to show off
yeah you trying to i think snake snake
is exotic so she'll probably dig that
that's a good point huh
and then you can do the old snake to
snake trick yeah
yeah you know
like there's only one snake left and i
know yeah yeah and then you go you got
this thing it's gonna spit girl
that's too much
sorry
but if you have something you got to
grill up what if a thanksgiving y'all
start a small family in there you still
trapped in this place it's been a few
years what are y'all cooking them guinea
pigs are getting it there doesn't have
meat on guinea pigs i don't think damn
bro
don't think i would never eat them they
have little pigs and uh some pet stores
too right no bro
2022 they can't have any of that i think
you can i would say yeah you're just one
pig in there yeah yeah i'm going for the
pig there's hamsters this is like fish
and snakes bro this is like korean
supermarkets
they just pull it push the card up to
the aquarium and just dump the whole
thing in no and crickets too they have
crickets for now
brother yeah they've got crickets i've
had uh whatever
crickets yeah i've had those big worms
too these centipedes that you have
and i went there and there you go right
there so count mini pigs bro reel that
[ __ ] up can we get one
for the office i'll buy one for the
office who's gonna take care of it
though uh everybody
well that means no one that means yeah
we need to feel like designated
you can stay at your house monday
wednesday friday big george takes them
tuesday thursday saturday sunday you
guys switch like a divorce family or
yeah big george takes them i'd grill
that little bastard up i'll be honest
with you dude i'm gonna name pork chop
tonight but that that's dude that's a
played out name bro i think for i'm to
be honest with you brendan oh do you
know a lot of people with mini pigs
named pork chop
they hang out with the wrong friend look
it up bro on tick tock there's like 70
mini pigs in pork chop really i think
you need to go with something a little
bit more like um like what what's the
lady's name from the titanic rose yeah
that's romantic dog but imagine you just
keep playing the titanic music every
time that pig comes in the room
that's beautiful dude oh you played
darth vader
really yeah blackie i feel like i can't
use that
you could probably still use it if he's
a black like all black pig dude i'm just
grateful for everybody man that's what i
want to say me too man i'm glad you i'm
glad you're here brother i mean yeah man
too man i missed you too dude i'm glad
you're still alive and i'm glad that
i've been on the road dog
have i been oh i went to oklahoma
actually
great time out there i love oklahoma and
then at some shows in la i want to thank
everybody that came out in la man for
the during the netflix's joke festival
and netflix didn't do [ __ ] to promote
our shows they promoted all these other
fancy [ __ ] and they didn't do anything
but everybody came up and showed out hey
look at me i want to thank people you
know that was going to happen though but
here's my thing here's my thing brother
you don't need them i know you don't
need anybody i know that but
you release his own special on youtube
you don't need anybody dude i want to
say thank you to everybody that came out
and uh yeah i agree it's just like yeah
you think yeah i guess party you just
think that they would give you a little
bit of help here and there you know
drives me nuts brother drives me and
look at this trevor wallace look used to
making out under a street lamp baby
mexican mistletoe dawg
did they look at you when you were
recording
they had been at the show i go outside i
just been talking about this i catch
them in the wild bro smooching under a
street right there what's the odds dude
mexican people love to kiss outdoors
it's one of the beautiful traits of
latinos though yeah man that's street
street taco street kissing street
everything french
street birth i think you probably dog
you hang out in the right circle dog you
catch a little uh
you know
and what do you guys eat chin
what do we eat yeah man on the street
i did look up water discrepancies yeah
yeah that much didn't come with much
water discrepancies i'll tell you
something that's happening is the
aquafire from uh all the water from
colorado
that we're they're not going to be
sending it down here it's not even
making it to california anymore well
here's the thing california knew some
this one's for free if you just get rid
of the goddamn almonds here it takes all
of our water if we got rid of almonds we
wouldn't have a drought almonds look it
up
almost almonds you want fresh water bro
look at almond joys though oh daddy
favorite candy god sometimes you feel
like you're not sometimes don't yeah
feel has not
bren don't
mounds don't baby you got them [ __ ]
dude
what is this water shoulders kind of
really cool eventually but i you know
what also i bet if you look through
every other week in every newspaper this
article has been printed everywhere 110
percent
what other way
what is this guy what happened if he's
doing poster work look at that look at
this the main issues associated with
almond milk production are water use
which may produce long-lasting effects
on environment and drought-stricken
california where more than 80 percent of
the world's almonds are grown
[ __ ] almonds dog
water almonds bro
waters an almond pick your poison dude
waters are almond
you have water or almonds you can't have
but leave me alone
i like allman bro all right man damn dog
i like almond milk i feel like this is
like the shittiest law firm river waters
are almond
welcome to waters and almonds
we are [ __ ] did you get an accident
turn to water than almonds
we don't get paid until you get paid
we're thirsty as [ __ ]
we're still thirsty we're thirsty for
your lawsuit
our mouth are dry from all these almonds
yeah we're thirsty to get you the money
you deserve water's an almond
baby gets hit by a car
like whoa whoa the water is at all too
much man dude and a lot of fake babies
have still been happening and having
apparently a new thing as chicks are
pushing fake empty strollers around to
get clout you know
and a lot of gay men are
really yeah let's say that somewhere
look that up
you are on the streets more than i am so
i don't want to hate on it well it's
fine
it's the truth though now are you seeing
the same kind of uh maybe situation in
nashville too or this is just really an
la thing
oh no this is coast to coast daddy
desperate for merchandise use fake look
at this huh wow i thought you were
making this up fake babies oh
people man
that's when it's it boy a baby you can't
even have a [ __ ] real baby anymore
you bring a real baby they're testing
him to see if he's reeling [ __ ] bro what
a brawl make him crawl
like [ __ ] what do you mean he's [ __ ]
eight days old
whatever make him wiggle
weird that's [ __ ] just make him weird
go make him [ __ ] his pants homes uh i
feel like phil would rent out his kid
just to make a dollar there i don't know
if you can i don't think legally you can
do that that's trafficking isn't it ooh
that is trafficking 101 isn't it where
was that the other day and someone was
like is this trafficking and i'm like i
don't think this is i bet you're at
orange julius uh i don't know where
i feel like a lot of human trafficking
happens that orange julius that place is
shady man this stuff's heartbreaking
dude yeah it is i think if it you just
can't be meeting people off
craigslist hey who would get more money
in sex trafficking you or me
wait we did this already didn't we no
that's only fans dude i'm talking that's
legit and nobody's getting touched i'm
talking real human trafficking you and
me i don't think i think
i feel i feel like they would come they
would start with you right because you
got you look better than me you got that
fat ass but eventually like he doesn't
shut the [ __ ] up he just tells all these
weird stories non-stop man we want a
refund can we trade him in with the kid
with brain damage that's what you think
yeah but can we trade in for the big
boy's brain damage but then also who's
sex trafficking a kid with brain damage
that is the worst that is like dark
yeah like this guy's got one debate club
but what about i was going to start
first of all this is all very sad and it
shouldn't be here and if chris we don't
even think we can discuss this
but i do think that
um
the thing about uh
sec you have to think of a lot it's it's
a long game dude i think
who would be able to survive in the
streets and in the [ __ ] trap houses
getting you know taken around like in a
train car
i probably won't do very well with that
i feel like i feel like you've been in
trap houses
i don't know if i have been
i mean i've been in some [ __ ] very
sketchy sleepovers you know where people
are wide awake crap okay jared's sister
was there it's a long game though chin
who do you think who would survive
better
and look let's don't say sex trafficking
because that's like for kids i think and
stuff no that's not everybody that's
that refers to everybody yeah
it's a dark art yeah dude you should
call your next special trap house really
yeah
hold on if one of us were getting put on
the black market for sensuality
who do you think would have the longer
lifespan out there remember i can fight
now if i have to that's the thing you
can fight skill set oh that's true but
theo can talk i think he can talk his
way out of anything so i don't know it's
a tough but it's not you you're not
getting out you're just in there so it's
like who's gonna they're probably gonna
be nicer to you
i think like sweeter to you like it's
gonna get you killed what you gotta do
is just relentless no if they're like
hey man your your ass game is crash
we're just gonna have you shake down
these people for money
but then you're doing something
different then you're like you're now on
a different profession i'm saying who's
staying in that body game you are
i'm not that asking be worn out daddy
i don't want it i don't want that
happening to you either
if you just let it happen you can have a
long career i think yeah i don't want
that
i feel like i'm have a little more fight
me i feel like feels like just get it
over with yeah ah this guy wants to hear
about your morning routine okay
what's up king the sting and the wing
and guess what i got a debate club for
you
not herpes on my lip my name is barry
i'm from georgia i have a debate club
i've already said it twice go ahead and
make fun of it brennan anyways
how do you guys get through your
mornings you know i got to buy a box of
damn advils and some knock-off gatorade
monster crap with some
energy in it so i don't fall asleep
because i get up so damn early but
besides a black americana or an ice
americana or
brandon eating baby food or theo crying
in the morning how do you guys get
through your morning
gang gang buzz buzz [ __ ] sore still
wakes up everywhere with a nice hard cry
yeah yeah
he's off into the races man oh i've
masturbated with my own tears brother
i'll tell you this um
and what is this guys lost
does he do that is it raining here's
what i would like to say is the morning
routine is crucial it's everything it's
crucial man what do you do brother what
i do i get up make my bed say my prayers
and i uh
are you in the barbie i do a meditation
bro i gotta do all of this [ __ ] to try
to stay alive dude i didn't eat today so
also if i seem snappy or i'm talking to
you about too many menu items then
i haven't eaten so i can feel my blood
sugar getting low this thing i wouldn't
survive i don't think in the trap houses
dude but that's what i do food as long
as they give you snacks you'd survive
yeah if there's a snack dish on the edge
of the bed i can handle it
it's the dark web
the second that the almond milk you know
hits the scene
that's another thing you got to think
about is who's going to really be
wanting to get all of that semen on them
yeah that's a good point that glazed
donut man but
i've known theo so well for so long i
know not to talk business or anything
before noon needs to get his day going
get those exercise them demons every
morning and i wait till 12 to discuss
anything with you oh 1201 call him
what's up dog and he's way better before
12 it's jekyll and hyde before 12. it's
jekyll after it's hide and i like hide
so i went to 1201 to talk to theo now me
i got kids so i'm up at 5 36 every
single morning i get those little
rugrats we go downstairs i make the
strongest coffee you've ever tasted in
your [ __ ] life daddy's popping so i
and i usually don't eat i fast all
morning and then when i get to uh on my
way to the gym i stop at starbucks i get
an eight shot iced espresso i down that
go to the gym then i come to the studio
oh damn huh
same routine every single day
and also with that strong coffee like
the 50 cent of coffee i feel like
you can be my game dog
and also with that eight with that
strong coffee in the morning it's death
wish coffee it's the most caffeinated
coffee in the world i do uh four
four things of uh
nicotine it's so crazy and daddy is
hitting the ground running
running okay
vibrating forward i feel like
uh at the speed of nicotine yeah um no
look man i might get caterpillar on meth
you gotta keep it cruising dude you
gotta keep it cruising you're an
inchworm bro but a [ __ ] you're a
footworm
yeah you got to stay i think you got to
stay busy out there man i think it just
it matters what your needs are dude but
yeah i think doing something physical
doing something meditative to start out
those are good ways to go bro yeah i
think and i think a goodness sounds
super corny but in therapy i learned
this is waking up and being thinking of
something to be grateful for every
morning otherwise you start off on the
wrong foot oh yeah yeah you can't be
angry and great grateful at the same
time
conflicting emotions
yeah you just go back and forth okay
yeah i'm uh gringry
i've got a really interesting situation
for you here's a young guy and this is
nick obviously before something happened
to him
oh was it really you said that
looks just like that i've got one for
you
yo what up king and the sting matt
coming at you from ontario canada and i
got a bit of a king understand for you
today so i'm 21 years old and i'm a
boilermaker apprentice
and i'm working at an old nuclear
reactor right now
old reactor it's been running for about
30 years and i pick up these small
to medium doses of radiation and it's
like
supposedly safe
that's what the government says but you
never [ __ ] know right so they pay me
pretty good that's the other side of it
so
can't understand it
stack these racks all the way up to the
[ __ ] sky
have no dents
and then you know maybe have some
glowing piss or a second [ __ ] or you
know
what who knows what'll happen or yeah
you know find work elsewhere
not have as big of a stack
and uh but keep my nuts safe maybe have
kids one day
but anyways that's all i got for you
guys today um
i [ __ ] love you guys
gang gang buzz buzz chris i'll see you
at the log cabin i got my white shirt
and yeah peace
well yeah stay away from that toxic [ __ ]
that you're doing my man i mean it's the
origin story the teenage mutant ninja
turtles you got to get away from that
dude i don't care how much they're
painting yeah like all that radiation is
this chernobyl i mean what's watch
chernobyl on hbo doggie it's not healthy
man
i think it depends on how you look at it
i mean i think here's here's a young guy
he obviously has some years to kill
you know he could spare you know five
something happens to him or whatever i'd
say 10 yeah well you could do it look i
said i see people go to jail for murders
seven years
that's [ __ ] if i'd have known i could
have killed somebody at 20 i've only
gotten and been out at 27. yeah you'd be
doing me a favor i missed 20 to 26 man
dude are you gonna hang out with the
homies i'll tell you this this kid some
of my neighborhood fat randall would
have been dead okay i'll tell you that
straight up boy
you lucky randall yeah so anyway things
is different you know but look guy i
think you handsome enough you could even
lose you know you could go from an eight
to a seven you're still gonna make it if
one of your jaw you know like a portal
opens up in your jaw over there because
you work it over there you start growing
a tooth out of your neck my man every
time putting your two-week notice yeah
if you're working over that willy
wonka's magic plutonium factory dog you
know
look if you take a dump and it crawls
back in your butt that's when you gotta
put in the pit
but until then bruh write it out in
documentation that's key because a lot
of people they go to the government you
know they're out there aaron brockovich
and [ __ ] but they don't they didn't
record it they didn't do it at least get
somebody go somewhere get somebody to
draw a picture of you this is when he
was healthy yeah take a before and after
picture yeah you need every day you need
to look a little bit worse start dyeing
your eyebrows white that's what i would
do here green take it but dude look man
if you're gonna do it go all the way in
get the wheelchair
um my buddy used to do this thing where
he put up magnets in the wheelchair and
the feet part and so they would kind of
like go like that all the time and it
like made it look like he had the
tremors right
because they would try to tourette's
almost the magnets would try to attract
to each other so right when he rolled in
the courtroom you're like oh [ __ ] dude
he's all rattled outside the money
that's not a bad hustle at all you gotta
do before and after picks you're gonna
look like obama after his [ __ ] eight
years in the white house yeah be lit
dude you might grow some horns yeah and
you could end up like tom ford or
whatever the guy that was the [ __ ]
mayor of uh
wherever it was canada
uh
died
doing crap
but yeah if you're doing plutonium bro
dude i would definitely tell the ladies
too you know i got the magic stick yeah
what i'm saying
yeah you tell me around that toxic [ __ ]
all the time i had only bad things might
get this giant
[ __ ] monster dick you know that's
what i would do
you're crazy man and they say also it
can make your balls small and it can
make you can have a kid that doesn't
have any fingernails oh yeah yeah yeah
some huge side effects if you want kids
my man i'd get out of there go work at
an orange
julius that guy was funny though he
should uh send us in more questions
about his life he's only 21. uh so was
it yeah won't you send in something else
dude just
yeah let's know how the ladies
department's going you're working around
this place or other things if you have
any issues with your body or whatever
like that uh what is it called
dysmorphia yeah if you because you don't
you can't even see his legs in the image
what that dick looked like dog what
what
bro he's sick bro he's around plutonium
all the time yeah but you want to see
that deal bro yeah the mushroom has
probably insane
dang bruh
you want to see that little bait that
little spear huh
you want to see that little nitrous
sphere here we go
theo
eric chris you know high school that's
an order from most ethnic to least
uh king understanding
jobs that make you wear uniforms
supposed to have this [ __ ] tucked in
supposed to have one you know what i'm
saying them rubber that outfits
sleep shoes but we're not doing that i'm
not one of them tuck shirt cuts yeah i'm
saying one of them
sucker dudes yeah so
you know can't understand it unis at the
job gang gang buzz buzz
when black people sing you just believe
they can sing even if they can isn't
that interesting yeah
um i'll say this man a uniform i got you
know i did drugs once and uh
mailed my uniform off i was high on
drugs
to get money for it for drugs no i was
in the mail room i worked in the mail
room and i was just all [ __ ] up and
put all my clothes into a box and mailed
them to one of the companies that we
worked with
and i left out of there nude got laid
off yeah yeah forgot about it right came
back the next day
like a week later
they got my clothes in the mail
so they can't say i was a bad male
person i just
you know i issue with the uniform and
drugs
yeah i was a janitor man so i had to
wear that janitorial outfit man that
what the onesie the you know i would
still wear jumpers that's a call back to
when i was a janitor my first job and i
also got fired from that it's crazy how
a jumper is a guy like to commit suicide
and also like a cute outfit yeah
that [ __ ] is cute a men's jumper is cute
i don't give a [ __ ] a romper but i'll
tell you right now them girls mm-hmm and
uh cherry creek
with all their money they treat me like
[ __ ] and there's a janitor treat me like
[ __ ]
a lot of men trying to be gay too that
skunk pumper they call them skunk
bumpers i think
the janitors are skunk bumpers oh i
don't know i don't i've never i mean i
had some issues with some janitor guys
by us but but there was also a lot of
nepotism in the janitor and
uh there was a lot of nepotism in the
janitor industry near us
because people uh
that taught at the schools would hire
their
uh men you know people as mentally on
wells and they would have them come and
do the um janitorial and do uh
you know uh
custodial yeah probably not even a
passion for cleaning no i don't have a
passion for it i was 16 you should make
me pick the cigarettes of the ashtrays
by hand which took forever at 5am and
then i got fired because you remember
you put a nickel in you could grab
whatever candy you want i'd fake like i
put nickel in and then i'd grab all the
candy and grab all the magazines they'd
like who the [ __ ] is reading all the
magazines i'll just sit in there and
pretend i was cleaning the bathroom for
hours
and then they made me work on the super
bowl when the broncos in the super bowl
i was like i [ __ ] quit son we quit
for no reason yeah well to watch the
super bowl they wanted me to work during
the denver broncos super bowl run when
john you worked there yeah i worked
there yeah that's why they wanted you to
work talk that's a good point it wasn't
just like just randomly just driving up
to the denver broncos super bowl though
come on daddy you gotta give me the day
off but you knew two weeks in advance
because the afc championship was two
weeks prior you couldn't put in to get
out of uh that day these are fair points
man yeah my bad man i used to work at
this place i got hired over there and
some dude at the end of the shift would
show everybody he would draw like for
like the bus boys and stuff i
forgot about this this dude would draw
like how to do oral sex on women and he
would like act it out like with like
these
um
like uh the origami no
no like a melon like he would do he
would do like uh
what is it called cantaloupe and he
would cut that thing open and
it was insane now that i think about it
is absolutely crazy sounds like i forgot
but we would it was a real nice place it
was called wine and cheese
and uh just wine and cheese
yeah but that's a llamas it's a huge
yeah look up wine and cheese how many
images you get
forty thousand two hundred thousand
cheese but look it up
it's just wine and cheese and where was
this was in your hometown this was over
there in mandeville louisiana 522
million wow
yeah and this was called dakota's wine
and cheese
and it was uh you're typing wine and
cheese restaurants it was off highway
22. but look at the image right there
look at all the imagery look at that
listen i like a nice chocardery board
look at the wine
board look at the cheese boy
so what i'm saying is this baby what
happened was uh
what i'm [ __ ] hungry i'll eat one of
my damn thumbs
oh dude you need that whole [ __ ]
board or wife huh
oh dude i'll [ __ ] i'll blow my wrist if
it lets me eat its thumb
that's what i'm telling you bro i will
i will [ __ ] my hand if it lets me
if it lets me eat two of its fingers
dude i am [ __ ] hungry you freaks
and i called earlier and said why we
don't have nothing to eat mark's going
to give his food right now he could have
left earlier
what we're doing you can't eat on here
nobody's out here doing drinking a water
okay
drinking a water when there's a drought
this [ __ ]
[Laughter]
he's drinking water and hamilton tony is
sitting over here
slurping down water like damn napoleon
bonaparte
i better have some good time codes
yeah for real yeah god
i'm gonna dance we need to feed you
before you turn to [ __ ] gremlin
i know i'm just not doing well today man
you seem like you're doing well i can
usually tell like this really oh yeah
you're doing good buddy i'm doing you
know i'm doing good and bad at the same
time that's what i think is going on
yeah
it's a real rattler you know
it's like i'm headed for the gutter the
bumpers are in though i got the bumpers
yeah the bumpers in let's not knock the
bumpers down the lord's helping me but
it's like man i think not having any
food and everybody talking about things
they're eating well you've basted 40
times out eating dogs and [ __ ]
gerbils
that's on you
quick what are you grateful for
i'm grateful that
uh
ryan is going to get us
ryan
we've seen this guy before yeah he's one
of my favorite submitters i'm grateful
that uh yeah i'm grateful that we just
got to feed you dog that's easy it's
getting done right now yeah and i'm
going to georgia coming up soon i'm
grateful i get some peach pie over there
uh you're on tour in georgia yeah let's
get some shows over there so i'm excited
augusta savannah you been there uh no i
never been i've never been you're doing
dope markets big theaters too i'm proud
of you man it'll be interesting thank
you man it's gonna be great yeah i'm in
philly this week are you philadelphia at
the helium thursday friday brotherly
love man we love ben franklin stomping
grounds
i'm gonna get that cheese steak they put
the cheese whip the two different ones
too yeah
are you are you coming chin yeah i
remember oh [ __ ] i forgot you were
coming
shin's gonna [ __ ] deep throw a
cheesecake yeah cool i'll put it on the
ground for you
come on daddy come see chin deep throw
the [ __ ] cheesecake
cheese cake and cheesecake that's good
it looks so good what is this thursday
friday
[Laughter]
i'm just joking does it offend because i
i just don't like asian people when
people were like they eat dogs i hate
that because it's you have to eat things
in certain countries bro yeah if there's
a ton of them running around and you
have no resources it's always certain
it's only certain koreans
too well china does it oh yeah well
china [ __ ] with bats well china does a
lot of
coke yep but i'll say that [ __ ] right
out loud yup chyna did fentanyl and all
the coke that [ __ ] was good boy they
started making it in china that
fentanyl's trouble they're spending on
the damn shelving units buy a shelving
unit from china dude that [ __ ] has
fentanyl in it it should fall right off
dude but some fake jordans you get
fentanyl on them [ __ ]
sucks into your toes i've seen a million
times what's this gentleman what nick
this guy
he's been on i know how long is this
been going three hours does anybody work
here
it's one hour exactly it's been
recording where's your guys uniforms
[Laughter]
we should have some who the [ __ ] forgot
your uniforms no uniform is don't wear
[ __ ] sweats and sandals yeah we gotta
feed this man last one nick there's
nothing to eat in this whole
i got a king interesting it for you
buying the dip talking crypto nfts
stock
do we ride that doggo to the moon no i'm
pulling
out let me know gang gang buzz buzz ah
sore nice
i like the animal sound me too i would
whatever you made i would eat yeah uh
whatever sound that was nft crypto guy
the whole thing is called i want to this
is called a pyramid scheme ponzi scheme
yeah if you're not familiar with any of
it it is when somebody comes in and says
hey this is amazing this is going to
make you money overnight and you'll buy
it and then you lose money
tim dylan tells
yeah i got involved in a pyramid scheme
man yeah i hear that man uh when i was a
child and
lost all my money in one and i should
have known on the sheet of i remember
the guy showed me the documentation
and it was in the shape of a [ __ ]
period and it even said at the top i
swear to god it said pyramid and the
second word was scratched out
you still messed it yeah
i'm like doesn't it say pyramid
something
the guy's like nah this is old paperwork
this is old man and i went in on that
[ __ ] man all my money dude it was two
thousand dollars that saved up all that
god does and me and my friend did half
and half on it
we each went in on a thousand and lost
shame man and here's the craziest part
we went and told his parents about it
and they had also lost money on it
instead who you telling you the bastard
were out five g's
they couldn't even get mad at us because
they'd lost money but if you want to do
good you know it's not it's not a legal
proposition but yeah start some [ __ ]
it's like tim dillon says fake business
start it up
nfts [ __ ] dirty diaper clean through
the mail do something selling uh people
selling air from different cities and
stuff i saw one girl selling her fart in
a jar making bank yeah from tlc
some guy by us used to sell frozen water
from different areas of the country see
i'm into that people are
there's ways to make money you know what
i'm selling you can sell uh
animal skins and stuff through to
makeup i'll tell you right now crypto
nfd there's all that [ __ ] i don't know
how old he is but there ain't a better
investment than real estate son there's
more millionaires in real estate than
anything it's the long game you're never
gonna lose your ass on real estate it's
also been around forever you also don't
want to be able to be up if you can't do
property management you don't want if
you can't be there and deal with it then
you got to get property management
because otherwise somebody's texting you
we got to paint the porch the
refrigerator is broken and something
you're trying to lift my life my ac went
out and you're trying to do all that
[ __ ] don't buy a trap house that [ __ ] is
a disaster well they got hud housing in
section 8 housing dude you know dude
maybe we should invest in trap houses
instead of that [ __ ] zoo in mexico
i'm not getting involved i'm i am not uh
real estate to me is it's kind of
exhausting some of it having to deal
with it if i had a nickel for every time
i heard theo on an hoa call giving cindy
the business he's got a lot of issues
yeah because and some things you can't
get do you think that's a theo issue or
an hoa issue
i'll take it from here for five thousand
they sounded like a bunch of idiots and
he has no time to suffer fools
yeah and once you get in some of that
stuff you're locked in you can hire
somebody else to do it but they're not
going to do it the same way so sometimes
it's just risky you know i mean
everything has risk with it
so real estate's usually pretty safe but
i think you're probably right dude
getting in something good but also
everything's so expensive right now
i don't see where this goes well no
already the mortgage rates have gone up
so it's just a matter of time for it
goes back down and we're all good baby
but what does that mean that sounds
really good let's come back to it then
it's going to come back
any dude making handsome like this is
not true
look at this give me your money give me
your money
is that it that's it all right philly
i will beaten cheesesteaks with chen we
getting balding some cheese steaks this
thursday friday saturday helium
philadelphia all new one hour after
shooting the special if you haven't seen
the special we on track to hit a million
by next week son the gringo poppy
special on think boy youtube about to
hit a million so this week we're in
philly then next wednesday it's shopping
friends the hollywood improv with some
monsters them in portland oregon june
9th through the 11th san francisco cobbs
june 17th through the 18th san diego lab
factory ridiculous new club in the heart
of san diego that's july 21st through
the 23rd but philly you're up this week
come get some from your boy tickets at
thickboy.com
i want to say this thank you guys for
all your support thank you guys for
coming out and just supporting uh
us any of us and uh for supporting me as
well
um
i'm really grateful and i i've just
gotten to see some of you guys in
albuquerque and
tonight i'm over here in midland texas
as this comes out
so that's exciting lubbock texas i will
be in tomorrow night and dallas this
saturday then coming up i'm in savannah
june 2nd
i am in augusta june 3rd montgomery june
4th
and uh columbus georgia on june 5. tell
your friends tell your cousin somebody
come on out
let god see uh see what we're doing and
have a good time out there go see one of
the best to do it man theo vaughn my
brother from a completely different
mother man amen and in july 3rd i will
be in las vegas uh also so we're going
to put that up and you can uh find all
those at theovonn.com
tour philly see you this week love you
guys buzz buzz gang gang baby old school
it's the king and the sting back up
[Music]
all
[Music]
legendary trio bringing chris and theo
what you mean demon was the king and the
sting and the wing